scene one all right all right take three
marker defense calls Colonel Nathan
jessep all right all right all right
let's do this would you state your name
rank and current bill it for the record
police sir Colonel Nathan are just
commanding officer an Academy Award
winner thank you sir did you wear that
uniform on the plane no lieutenant I
prefer to fly shirtless or of having no
earthly bond beneath my feet plus I like
being shirtless prawns having this
meeting you gave lieutenant Kendrick and
order is that right that's right that's
right that's right I told no always take
the long way when the boom blox your pad
can you explain it I told him it takes
three to tango especially in Barcelona
and did you give in order to Colonel
Markinson as well I told him jkl just
keep livin and at present Colonel
Markinson is dead is that right oh whoa
that's a bit of a Down hey everybody
okay if I take off my shirt part of
mourning process did you order the Code
Red it is Code Red to remove my shirt
I'm gonna post oculus hey I'm sorry a
homeless that sort of mouth Colonel just
did you order the Code Red hey you
better lighten up you want a pup I think
I'm entitled won't me get you brought
the truth all right here's true did you
order the Code Red did I mention I want
an Academy Award
you